my pleasure now to be joined by brian
billick super bowl winning head coach
he's in the ravens ring of honor coach
it's been a minute
how you doing dan helen how you doing
young man good to hear your voice
uh you as well thank you so much for
coming on really appreciate the time
you have been a man who's been around a
lot of fine quarterbacks and fine
offenses over your years
trevor lawrence obviously the number one
pick in this draft who's your number two
and number three when you watch these
guys
yeah it's an interesting group you know
you've got the five and it's a very
diverse group
in terms of the schools uh their
athleticism their experience their base
uh so it's an interesting diverse group
to choose from
zach wilson appears to have and i think
it looks like maybe the jets are going
to take zach wilson he looks to be the
the total package
they all look like that you know they
should be able to play in the nfl
having said that you know 50 of the
players taken in the first round
at quarterback bust i mean that's just a
fact and so the question is which of
these guys
there's no reason this group should not
be all good quarterbacks of course there
was no reason
why jamarcus russell and vince young and
achilles smith and
joey harrington and the list goes on and
on why they shouldn't have been good
pros
so it's going to be interesting to see
the order they come off
so when you're building a team i've had
this debate many times with
uh friends and colleagues over the years
ideally
you find your young quarterback you
build the team around him
however there are certain times when you
build the team and then you plop the
young quarterback in
is that something doable or is is
having your young quarterback first much
more uh preferential if you are
a team builder or a head coach as you
were yeah it's it's tough
to do the latter you know you can see
why new york and and
and i i concur that that setting sam
darnold the carolina made sense because
robert sala comes in at a chance to
visit with him the other day
on a podcast that i do coach to coach
and
and that's usually the formula that when
you come in as first
as a coach if you get your quarterback
if unless there's one there already
but if if you need one to have it right
when you get started and then you build
around them
the problem is if you if you start to
build the team and you try to plop them
in later
you're gonna go through the ups and
downs of a young quarterback and
and you may not laugh we've seen that
story time and time again
so yeah i do think it it makes a
difference that if you're gonna pick a
young quarterback
unless you're an established team an
established head coach
that is firm in your in where you're at
um
yeah if you're just starting out yeah
you want to start with that young
quarterback that's exactly why i think
urban meyer
uh took the jacksonville job because his
ability to begin with trevor
lawrence and and i think probably one of
the reasons that robert sala was drawn
toward the jets job
having that second overall pick and
could start that process
together with his young quarterback dan
helly filling in for rich eisen talking
to
super bowl winning head coach brian
bilick who has authored a
book on finding the ideal nfl
quarterback so who better to talk to in
this draft where
every nfl team seemingly so thirsty to
find that franchise quarterback and we
could see
we're going to see three go one two
three that's only happened twice before
uh in nfl history and you mentioned the
50 bust rate
it was 1971 it was uh 1999
and there were six quarterbacks taken uh
in three
in the first three picks of each of
those drafts and three made it and three
didn't so there's your 50
bus rate right here if you're the
falcons
brian and you have the fourth overall
pick and you have the opportunity to
potentially find a
future franchise quarterback uh who
could sit for a year behind behind matt
ryan
or take maybe the most dangerous
offensive weapon in the drafting kyle
pitts
what do you do yeah i still think matt
ryan can play and i think the atlanta
falcons can be a good football team
i uh you know i don't we just said
you're a first time
coach now's the time to start with young
quarterback i get that and atlanta wants
to do that fine
let matt ryan go someplace else and
there'll be a lot of suitors
the idea of letting him okay we're going
to draft a guy
we're going to use that first pick not
to make the team better but to draft a
guy not
playing and now let matt ryan continue
to take it on
that typically doesn't go well i mean
yeah you can look at
kansas city when they did with patrick
mahomes queen alex smith
and you look at jordan love uh
um in green bay and behind uh aaron
rodgers but those are two good football
teams atlanta is not a good football
team right now
so to put in no matter who they take if
they take one of these quarterbacks he's
gonna start at some point that's just
the way it works
and uh and for matt ryan to be that
place holder
i i just don't think it's in atlanta's
best interest to do that i don't think
it's matt ryan's
best interest if you want to go that
route and i can certainly see that
then then let matt ryan go someplace
else and and there'll be a long
line of shooters that wanting to have
matt ryan so
many have said that the draft starts at
number four right where that where the
falcons are because we know that
quarterbacks are going to go one two
three
is there a most interesting pick in this
draft beyond the atlanta picket four
you know a lot of people have also
talked about the fact that the panthers
despite the fact they've traded for sam
darnold could
draft a quarterback somebody's probably
gonna move up into the top 10 to draft
one of these guys to you
what's the most interesting scenario or
team there in you know the
the top half of the first round well
obviously the quarterback draw
drives that and and what you just laid
out will be interesting
if carolina takes a quarterback after
trading for
for uh uh sam bradford that that's going
to be a cluster
i mean that's just not good um i realize
it's not a huge cost on their port
because they're really kind of paying
them like a backup so that works but i
i you know that to me that's just not a
good if you're going to take the young
guy then take the young guy
and let him be the guy and build going
forward with that
what's interesting is you look at the
nfc east with dallas new york and
philadelphia
10 11 and 12. because of all these
quarterbacks getting pulled up
there's some good top five blue chip
talent
whether it's the two tackles the slater
and sewell
whether it's like you say kyle pitts uh
whether it's so you know those good
jamar uh jamar chase right uh or devonta
smith
there's some pretty good top five
talents getting pushed back
to that nfc lineup of dallas new york
and philadelphia
that make it very very interesting and
could make it even not for the
quarterback
for someone wanted to jump up uh if
let's say carolina decides no we're not
gonna
take a quarterback we're gonna go with
sam darnold someone wants to
jump up and pick up one of those
quarterbacks it presents them an
opportunity
now to pick up still maybe a top five or
top ten talent later on back so
that movement you're exactly right and
pointing it out uh at detroit carolina
and denver that's that's going to be
very interesting to see where that falls
yeah to you to your point about really
good players falling look on the
defensive side of the ball there might
not be a defensive player
uh picked until 11 or 12 and you could
get a guy like micah parsons who
might be the best defensive player in
this draft so that's going to be
fascinating to see
i'm fascinated by the draft rooms and
what goes
on behind the scenes and you've been
in many of these over the years and
involved in many drafts from your from
your days in minnesota to your time in
baltimore
as the head coach and i believe you were
in minnesota when you guys
drafted randy moss correct coach yeah
sure
was that your single greatest draft pick
of all time
that was that was pretty good i remember
denny green came to me and denny green
god rest his soul was the best evaluator
of talented any coach i've ever been
around
would have been a great general manager
and and ran the draft beautifully and i
remember when he came
he said brian we're going to get randy
moss i think we are 21 or 22.
well okay the old man's lost it there's
no way randy moss is going to
i've done my homework even though i knew
there's no way he's going to get there
right um once he got past dollar 10 or
11
there was a free fall and all of a
sudden now 21 we get a randy boss
and it was i mean it was interesting
chris carter called me and he had been
working out with chris carter and chris
carter used to have a workout camp yeah
down at boca the fast program i remember
that yeah and
and and he called and he said brian you
this is unbelievable you can't believe
how good this guy is no chris is
unbelievable i'm looking at the film
right now
we're going to be able to do this and
that this he goes brian no listen to me
you have no idea how good this kid is
and chris saw it then
and so yeah that was uh that was one of
the special draft days to be able to get
randy moss at 21.
i'm look i'm looking at the numbers here
it's rookie here
holy cow was 1998 randy moss
had 69 catches all right that's okay for
1300 yards
and 17 touchdowns yeah yeah
you talked about the guy that could take
the top off the deep and and keep in
mind now i also had hall of famer
uh chris carter for that underneath in
the slot
i had robert smith in the backfield uh
randall cunningham at quarterback
um uh was jake yeah
we had some guys a great offensive line
i mean we had some
weapons defenses just didn't know what
because you had to start accounting for
randy
so you had to back up well we could wear
you out with chris underneath or run the
ball and uh
randy was unbelievable that rookie year
oh what
what an incredible player uh he was so
you get to baltimore
what what do you remember most about
your your time in baltimore in terms of
being in the draft rooms and picking
guys i'm assuming ed reed was probably
your best
your best pick there because ray lewis
had already arrived right
yeah i know oxy newsome in the group
whether it was phil savage or eric
costa did such an incredible job and you
asked about the draft room
if you do your work right uh it's a very
calm day
uh there's not like you know it's not
like in the movie uh draft was a draft
day with traffic
yeah where they consolidated an entire
season into like this guy did all this
in one day
you know he did that evaluation he did
this trade that this doesn't work that
way
all that work has already been done
you've set the table
now it's just a matter of pulling the
trigger if you want to move up move back
you've done your evaluations your guys
are going to be there
uh there may be some surprises thrown at
you very
not likely in the first round those
conversations tend to get a little more
in depth
later on because now you have you know
the difference between the the 10th
player in the draft and the
25th player in the draft could be
substantial and it's easy to quantify
but the difference between the the 50th
pick in the draft
and the 70th pick of the draft may not
be as clear-cut
and now you also have some needs so now
you know
you begin to negotiate the ranking on
the board
well we don't really need a lineman and
that's the next highest-rated guy
but this defensive lineman who we do
need isn't really quite as high
but almost so do you go with the defense
so that's where some of the
conversations become a little more
more more in day two and three well and
you were lucky enough to be a part of an
organization
that was among the elite in terms of the
structure
uh in the nfl with the ravens you know
ozzy and those guys in the front office
were
as and are as good as it gets
how much input did you have as a head
coach
and you won early you won a super bowl
early in your tenure there
did you have more after you had a little
more sway and
swagger in that room after winning the
super bowl well and ozzie was a great
partner and we did work
like a partnership i viewed my job to be
the guy that kind of stirred up
i mean we had a structure and ozzie was
one of the best listeners i've ever been
around
so he sought all of the input from
coaches and scouts alike and it was a
constant process
i viewed my job as to kind of stir it up
a little bit to you know
challenge one of the coaches or the or
the personnel guys on
on their guide they're selling them and
talking about how good he is
i may think the same thing but i may you
know yeah i'm not seeing it i'm not
convinced show me the tape
you know i want to see the courage of
his conviction and with ozzie i would i
would
pose questions tell me more about this
guy tell me more about that guy to
to get you know a little dig a little
deeper and
although it got to the point it was
usually about this time maybe even a
little earlier in the week where
kind of like with your wife you know
when you get that look like okay i've
had enough
we're done talking about it i i would
monday or tuesday i'd get that look from
ozzy like
okay we're done discussing it uh we're
set
what year was it when you were in
baltimore i believe it was 03
and the vikings missed their first round
pick because they were trying to work
out a trade with you do you remember
that
yeah it was a we it was all around byron
leftwich
and jacksonville wanted to do moba we're
all trying to move to minnesota you get
up to get byron leftwich and
and thought we had a deal and then it
was they were delaying and mike tights
couldn't pull the trigger and
the cards are being pulled in so as it
turned up
jacksonville ends up there minnesota
falls but then they missed their pick
because it was such a confusing we
actually had the card turned in
but it didn't get communicated properly
they've since changed the process
right so it was yeah it was a bit of a
cluster and and
and the guy we wanted i remember very
specifically
terrell suggs was a guy that that when
we would do the reading on trail
thugs um it would kind of be okay yeah
that's fine well there's no way we're
sitting at whatever
we were backed up there we weren't going
to get charles sucks he's not he's not
going to be available then so let's move
on
and and all of a sudden we're at we
thought that much of it
uh that he was that we thought he was a
top five blue chip player
so all of a sudden this thing's going on
and and then all of a sudden minnesota
is on the clock and we're thinking yeah
now we don't have vibrant lesbians
we don't have you know and now there's
that next pick and we're thinking oh my
god what did they take
and and they don't they delay we end up
getting subs
and then we scramble around and later on
take kyle bowler it wasn't until
later in the day where we kind of paused
and looked up and go
wait a minute are you kidding me we got
terrell suggs it was kind of you know
just the whole
way it went down was really unique yeah
my god it's just
well you could make movie after movie
about some of these draft rooms over the
years and
uh we certainly seen one in draft you
brought up jacksonville um
i just saw a tweet from uh from james
palmer at nfl network
um talking about urban meyer and urban
basically saying we can't screw this up
we have five picks in the first 65. it's
a historic draft we have to get this
right
what's the biggest challenge for urban
spending his whole career in the college
ranks you coached in college
prior to the nfl what's going to be the
biggest challenge for him in
jacksonville this year
well i had a chance to visit with urban
on the podcast i do coach to coach it
was fast i've known urban for years
and and he's ready for this there's no
question he's an outstanding coach
and coaching is coaching but it is
different obviously
the group you're dealing with the
professional yeah you have young players
but you're also going to have 30 and 35
year old veterans they've got families
and
side businesses and so dealing with the
pro
player mentality uh and the fact that
you're dealing with
with those grown men that's probably the
biggest adjustment and he'll do a great
job with it because you obviously
you you don't you you want to be fair
you're going to treat everybody
fairly but you're not going to treat
everybody the same you just don't
you're not going to treat a a long-time
veteran
um you know four-time pro bowler the
same way you do a rookie
you'll treat them fairly but differently
and so getting used to
that and and uh and and the fact that
you know he's been at some pretty good
programs where they look at the top
talent
on their board and they can get a whole
bunch of it that top 150 you're right
they have a lot of picks and he's going
to look at his top 150 players
and they look pretty good but those
those players come flying off that board
and all of a sudden it can look like
pretty slim picking so
it's a little bit different in terms of
trying to recruit them to great places
like florida
and ohio state and now you got to stand
in line to pick the players you want
seven years at ohio state he only lost
nine times urban meyer could lose nine
times in his first season
in jacksonville that's going to take
some some getting used to i think
for him at least in this in this first
year as he's building the program there
um if you are in san francisco and and
you're kyle shanahan and
you know every time your name pops up we
show the title of your book
uh you know the search the q factor of
uh the elusive search for
for a great nfl quarterback um
mac jones is kind of the i guess the
safe pick and the way that they're
they're leaning right now or do you go
after a guy like trey lance who has
unbelievable
upside when you have you know a veteran
quarterback there and jimmy g who could
kind of shepherd him through that
process
what do you do if you're san francisco
it's going to be interesting i know his
dad
mike mike shanahan a long time
coach in the league sure and outstanding
with quarterbacks and is
working with him as well um i i don't
know matt jones concerns me
the number three pick you don't take a
guy that can work the system
a system quarterback that you need
you take a guy in the early first round
there's got to be something special
about them and that's what i don't know
about mac jones
and it's not fair because mag we just
don't know matt jones
limited time starting he played behind
the best offensive line in football
throwing the best tandem receivers in
college football turned around and
arguably handing off to best running
back
in football so he's never really had to
put it on his shoulders we don't know
that he can't do it
we just haven't seen it so that's that's
the concern i would have for matt jones
trey lance you're right
he may have the biggest upside but he's
got the farthest way to go
as well so it's going to be interesting
that what they do
i will tell you this via the q factor at
the end of the day and i've heard it
from any number of people that was ron
wolf whether it was bill polian
people that have been doing this for a
long long time there has to be something
special about a guy you take you know
they all have the abilities like we said
uh and and that that's without question
uh but there's a lot you know that 50 50
equation
there's a whole list of guys that had
the ability should have been first-round
you know uh studs that ended up being
bust and the list goes on and on from
jamarcus russell to vince young to joey
harrington
to kelly smith ryan leaf i mean the list
goes on and on
these guys there's no question these
guys should be good i don't know what's
special about matt jones that would make
you take him at number three
yeah that is that is a fascinating pick
there and and then you have atlanta
coming up at four
dan helly on the rich eisen show filling
in for rich he's in cleveland we're
going to be talking with him in just a
moment right now
talking with super bowl winning head
coach and nfl network analyst
uh brian billick coach you've been so
generous with your time
and before i let you go i'm looking for
about a 40-foot
boat that i can take out when i'm back
uh home in maryland
on the chesapeake bay can you help me
out with that because i know you're in
the
business a little bit we'll find you one
invictus yacht we'll find something uh
i'm still in the boat business the
problem is
you know we sell uh used boats it's hard
to find
used boats when people aren't buying new
boats and because you can't get new
boats because of the cove and the whole
thing so that's the
we uh we don't have any inventory right
now but you want to do that you man i'll
get you
and i always like i always told you buy
your second boat first
right okay because whatever you get
you're going to want bigger so go to
that one first
get the second bow first i will uh i
will remember that coach anything you
want to plug i didn't
i mean i knew you had a podcast you were
doing michael robinson it sounds like
you have a whole slew of podcasts
anything you want to plug before we let
you go
one uh coach to coach that's i'm joined
i'm visiting with head coaches assistant
coaches
trying to give a voice to a lot of
assistant coaches as well also got one
you like this we haven't popped it out
yet we will
i'm doing a fishing podcast called the
coach and the fisherman no
i got a qualified up front i don't know
squad about fishing
you know i have a place up in the
northwoods near the canadian boundary
waters in minnesota
but i have access to a whole bunch of
guys that know how to it's been
fascinating we're talking uh muskie and
walleye and
trout and fly fishing and float fishing
and baits and and also
it's it's been great fun it's uh i'm
learning a lot
and fortunately i got some people who
know what they're talking about when are
you doing when does this come out and is
there is there a video component to this
you know we may at some point a lot of
people have been pushing me to do get
some pros to come up
my house is on lake vermilion it's god's
country man i'm about
uh 15 minutes south of the canadian
border
uh and it's beautiful country great
fishing
and we talked about maybe coming up and
having these guys coach me up and doing
doing the fishing but right now it's
just a podcast been great fun we'll see
if
i'm about to head back up there we'll uh
we'll see if i've learned anything from
these podcasts and
help me with my fishing you got to get
you have to go down to the keys and get
jimmy johnson on there i can only
imagine the conversations that you two
would have that'd be fantastic
there'd be a little beer involved that'd
be great
he's brian bellick in the ring of honor
for the baltimore ravens won a super
bowl
with them now working for nfl network
and in the uh the world of podcasts
brian
great catching up one of these times in
the summer
i i promise i'm going to swing by i want
to go out and
have a couple of beers with you on your
boat so we'll get that done
all right good talking to you hey you
watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here